les réseaux sociaux ou le calvaire d'un
chien était largement relayé fuji mort
le 19 août une femme accusée d'avoir
brûlé ce berger allemand de son
compagnon à comparaît devant le tribunal
de chalon sur saône depuis cet
après-midi 350 militants de la cause
animale s'ils sont également donnés
rendez vous des associations se sont
portés parties civiles
marie jolie isabelle rivière ils sont
350 à s'être rassemblés cet après midi
devant le tribunal de chalon sur saône
pour rendre hommage à fiuggi des membres
d'associations de protection animale
mais aussi de simples citoyens
ému par cette affaire notre devoir
puisqu'on défont les animaux c'est
d'être ici en hommage au fuji non pas
pour
crier faire une chasse aux sorcières
mais pour fuji matelas et puis d'une
autre source est bien évidemment que la
peine soit exemplaire
je trouve enfin très dur ce qui lui est
arrivé comment dire pourquoi faire ça je
n'ai pas cette question
c'est une question je comprends pas le 9
août dernier fugee un berger allemand de
9 ans est aspergée de produits
inflammables puis brûlé il décédera
quelques jours plus tard le procès de
l'auteur présumé des faits s'est ouvert
aujourd'hui pour le maître de fuji son
chien était plus qu'un animal de
compagnie c'est un chien qui m'a défendu
parce que la vie plusieurs fois dans mon
métier ce avant j'étais agent s'occupe
de sécurité avec lui c'est l'animal
d'une ville en fait quand on dit quand
les chiens d'une vive la ctc autre chose
son avocate espère obtenir une peine de
prison à l'encontre de l'auteur des
faits elle se veut aussi l'avocate de
fugee certainement mon client a souffert
de la perte de son chien je dis pas mais
celui qui a le plus souffert c'est quand
même fou ji qui a été enflammé qui a été
sur plus de 50 % de son corps qui a été
brûlé et qui est mort des suites de ses
blessures
vous rendez compte les souffrances de
cet être mais ça devait pas arriver au
21ème siècle ça l'audience est toujours
en cours le jugement de ce procès
devrait être connue dans les prochaines
heures
cette mobilisation des militants a donc
provoqué une agitation inhabituelle pour
ce procès mais il y aussi le contexte
l'accusé était donc la compagne du
maître du chien marie joly nous vous
retrouvons en direct de chalon sur saône
sommes-nous proche de l'issue ce soir
eh bien écoutez arnaud non pas du tout
parce que c'est un procès qui prend du
temps parce que vous l'avez vu ici il ya
beaucoup d'émotions une forte
mobilisation quelques personnes sont
toujours présentes et c'est d'ailleurs
la raison pour laquelle l'avocate de
l'auteur présumé des faits avait réclamé
un huis clos pour ne pas perturber
l'audience
huit clos qui a été refusée par le
tribunal
et puis c'est un procès qui prend du
temps parce que l'afer est beaucoup plus
complexe qu'elle n'y paraît il s'agit
d'arriver à comprendre les raisons qui
ont poussé cette jeune femme à passer à
l'acte et ce n'est pas simple c'est une
jeune femme qui vit dans un climat
social difficile qui est suivi
psychologiquement après avoir tenté de
mettre fin à ses jours
l'année dernière et c'est donc sur ce
profil psychologique que se penche en ce
moment même le tribunal les plaidoiries
et des parties civiles sont en cours
actuellement les réquisitions du
procureur vont suivre mais arnaud le
procès pourrait durer encore plusieurs
heures
merci marie gillain direct de chalon sur
saône